Speaker 1: Hello, everybody. Welcome to The David
Pakman Show. I'm producer Pat Forde, filling in
once again for David today as he is traveling up
north in Canada. But fear not because David will
be back with us at the end of the week. So let's
jump into some stories. Donald Trump is taking a
huge political risk and demanding that the full,
unredacted affidavit that led to his search
of his Mar a Lago home get released to the public
because he believes that it's going to vindicate
him. And the judge in the case, Bruce Rinehart,
actually may decide to call his bluff on this. The
affidavit, of course, was the evidence that was
used to convince Rinehart that there was probable
cause to conduct the search warrant at Mar a
Lago. Trump's spokesperson, Taylor BORDEWICH,
said about it, quote, President Trump has made
his view clear that the American people should
be permitted to see the unredacted affidavit
related to the raid and break in of his home. And
Trump himself made the same call on truth social
a.k.a. truth central posting. There is no way to
justify the unannounced raid of Mar a Lago, the
home of the 45th president of the United States,
who got more votes, by the way, than any
sitting president in the history of our country.
Not more votes than Joe Biden, by the way, by a
very large number of gun toting FBI agents and
the Department of Justice. But in the interests
of transparency, I call for the immediate release
of the completely unredacted affidavit pertaining
to this horrible and shocking break in. Also, the
judge on the case should recuse. Now, what exactly
should Judge Bruce Reinhart recuse himself for?
Nobody knows. And will Donald Trump ever
articulate why he should recuse himself?
Probably not. But it's just something you throw
out there, I guess. Judge Reinhart is actually
open to the idea of releasing the affidavit
with some of the appropriate redactions,
included the specifics of which are going
to be recommended to him by next Thursday.
But the Trump team, it's not good enough for
them. They want the full affidavit without
any redactions released to the public, which
really should be no surprise to us all, because
clearly Trump and his team are not too careful
about how they handle sensitive information,
which is exactly why he's in this mess to begin
with. Right? That's exactly why he decided to
bring those documents with him down to Mar a
Lago and put them in the basement. Redactions
would probably include cutting out some of the
names of the people involved in the investigation
of the former presidents. And they're totally
fine at the Trump team just saying, oh, don't,
don't cut out those names. Don't cut out the very
classified stuff that you don't want released to
the public because we don't care if people get
put in harm's way over this. Now, the call to
release the affidavit does seem to be a little
bit risky to Trump because it could reveal the
communications between the Trump team and the
DOJ ahead of the raid, which is when they asked
him for specific documents. And if this comes out,
this could totally debunk the claim that Trump has
been making, that he had this great relationship
with the DOJ and he was cooperating fully. Thus,
the raid was totally unnecessary. It could also
just provide further evidence of how exactly Trump
was mishandling classified information, which
again is not a good look for him. It seems like
the potential upside to Trump, though, is that if
the judge decides not to release the affidavit,
that's going to help him, because Trump could
say, Oh, look, they're not even being willing to
release all of the information.
They're not telling us why they're
investigating me. This is a witch hunt. They're
trying to keep everything secret. By the way,
it's not common for affidavits to get released to
the public. They're just considering it in this
case because of the public interest. So maybe the
Trump team, not that they make this ask knowing
that it wasn't going to be granted to them, but
Bruce Rinehart seemingly willing to call his bluff
and this could end up backfiring tremendously
on Trump and his team. So this is very much part
of the throw everything at the wall and see what
sticks strategy. Let's talk more about that next.